(gunfire resounds)
- The world has been
watching both a geopolitical
and a humanitarian crisis
unfold between Israel
and the Palestinians in the
Gaza strip in recent days.
Rockets from Gaza are striking in Israel,
and Israeli aircraft are pounding
a wide range of targets in Gaza.
Civilians are dying,
and there's no clear way
to bring this dramatic escalation
of violence to a conclusion.
(explosions resound)
In one sense, this
certainly is a new phase
in the decades-long conflict
between Israel and the Palestinians.
But in other ways, this outbreak
is just more of the same
and a sign that the new
phase some had hoped for
in this long-running conflict
isn't at hand at all.
First for starters, the outbreak shows
it isn't possible to simply
push the conflict between Israel
and the Palestinians to the back burner
as the Trump administration tried.
The Trump team thought Arab
states had grown so tired
of the Palestinian question
that they would merely
sidestep Palestinian demands
for their own state and return of lands
under Israeli control
and concentrate instead
on making peace with Israel
and confronting Iran.
- When you came into office,
Iran was on the march.
Because of your leadership,
Iran is now on the run.
- And that worked to
some extent as Bahrain,
the United Arab Emirates,
Morocco, and Sudan
all established formal ties with Israel.
The hope was that the Palestinian issue
would just fade in importance
as the Sunni Arab states
focused instead on confronting Iran.
But as the new violence illustrates
and as diplomats have
learned over the decades,
the Palestinian question has a way
of rearing its head over and over again
often when you least expect.
Second, this crisis shows
that it won't be as easy
to push Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
out of power as his critics
at home and abroad had hoped.
After Israel's fourth election
in two years recently,
Mr. Netanyahu had been unable
to form a new government
and his main opponent had
been given the chance,
but the current crisis is
pushing domestic politics aside
in Israel, and likely will
prompt some Israelis to rally
around their prime minister
in a time of duress.
That might actually extend
Mr. Netanyahu's long streak in power.
And finally, this crisis shows
that it isn't really
possible, at least not yet,
to detach Iran from the
broader Palestinian problem.
The extremist group Hamas
is firing the rockets
that are landing on Israel,
and Iran is the main
international supporter of Hamas.
And it was Iranian know-how
that largely helped
Hamas figure out how to produce on its own
the rockets it is now firing.
So the current crisis is showing
that the continued
importance of the alliance
between Iran and Hamas
is as strong as ever.
And indeed, this could end
up deepening that alliance.
In sum, while the crisis is
a dramatic new escalation
in tensions between Israel
and the Palestinians,
it also is in many ways
showing the old dynamics
are still in place and maybe
even growing more entrenched.
(soft instrumental music)